the rainforest has mutated since we
started talking as others I can't
conceive of a more difficult environment
to virtually steam the simulate because
the number of surfaces are you know in
the 10 hi nine range leaf surfaces every
shift of every minute of the day and the
lighting or the Sun goes behind a cloud
and presents you with a computational
problem greater than doing the General
Motors payroll for 10 years
see flowering plants didn't evolve until
65 million years ago there is recent as
mammals of the ecology of this planet
people don't understand this all
flowering plants which is 90 percent of
the Florida that are all new new
organisms before that it was all
coniferous and spore producing and firm
like plant life the reason the Amazon
rainforest is so species dense and so
highly integrated is because speciation
and natural selection have been going on
uninterrupted for 220 million years
that's why you can starve to death in an
Amazonian rainforest because no plant
elaborates free protein there aren't
luscious fruits and wonderful fleshy
things because anything which produce
those kinds of organs would be
non-competitive in such a tight
environment one of the strange things
about an Amazonian or Indonesian
rainforest is there is no
organic material that is not alive
something like 5% of the organic
material is nonliving so what that means
is if a leaf falls within 40 minutes
it's in many gods of hands it's being
chewed up by slugs it's being degraded
by bacteria there's no such thing as
detritus on the forest floor by the way
there is in a temperate to monocultural
forest - like we're familiar with do you
think compellingly good reasons for
trying to do something like well I'm
interested in whole systems and forest
ecosystems and stuff like that and
obviously being able to model these
things is the final proof that you
actually understand the processes maybe
the thing to model would be to start
with this would satisfy all kinds of
people who really get being a lot of
fancy experts helping an ant get a
forest
this raises problems in communication
too because of the pheromone angle it
raises problems in insect modeling macro
physical modeling there would be them
Skinner's I mean modeling an ant society
has implications for urban planning and
traffic country
language study and Wilson suggests that
this ability to concentrate food
production within the confines of the
nest and deep underground actually is
what gave these ants their evolutionary
lega and he compares it to the invention
of Agriculture he says the invention of
agriculture in human societies led very
directly to urbanization the building of
walled cities the production of
agricultural surplus and he compares it
to this adaptation invented six hundred
million years earlier where these
mushroom growing ants were able to
essentially take themselves out of the
stream of the natural Selective pressure
of the environment by creating an ant
defined environment underground in which
you know they are able to call the shots
and that's really what civilization is
then an ants an appreciation for ants
carries with it an automatic
appreciation
forms of communication and values that
are at first sight alien but on the
other hand ants have been around since
the Devonian so they must know something
about societal stability and equilibrium
and resource management and and those
sorts of things that we could use to
know you know an anthill is a mine and
each hands can be thought of as a nerve
you know that the interface between them
can be thought of as a CS into which
they produce pheromone of different
sorts to fire information across the gap
that separates the distinct dance so you
would probably find that your modeling
of the mask you know
it was turning into a kind of prototype
model of all kinds of complex
electrochemical systems which includes
human nervous systems human societies
intracellular networks of all sorts
[Music]